GONZALO RODRIGUEZ:
OK, thanks, everyone.
My name is Gonzalo Rodriguez.
I'm the CEO and
co-founder of Papumba.
We are a developer
of educational apps
for kids under the age of five.
And today, I wanted to mention
a couple of experiments
and things, learnings, that we
have in the last three years
while localizing our
apps and going global.
And I think it's
important, given
all that has been said today,
especially about the emerging
markets that are going to be
very important in the next two
years.
So hopefully, you'll
find it interesting.
There is a lot of data.
So hopefully it's
understandable.
So I already mentioned, we do
early educational apps for kids
under the age of five.
We focus in some
certain categories,
like learning the alphabet,
learning the numbers.
And we cover some
certain cognitive skills
from kids that are still
learning vocabulary,
like animal sounds, first words.
Until kids that have
reached the age of five,
and are ready to start school.
So we definitely promote
learning through play.
Our apps are a
combination of learning
methods that combine a lot
of gaming and interaction.
Especially because our
audience is so, so small.
They need to learn all
the time we're playing.
And at last, we
started the company
always taking into account or
with a vision of being global.
We started from day
zero with a problem
that I'm going to tell
you in the next slide.
Next slide, sorry.
I have the agenda.
And it has three parts
of the presentation.
First one is why did we
decided to go global.
And all the challenges
we had in the meantime.
Good challenges,
real fun challenges.
I really promote and will try
to transmit that these fun
challenges are really good.
And at last, some
experiments and results
that we can share with you.
And are very actionable
points and data
that we are going to share,
very intimate of our kitchen.
And I hope you'll find useful.
So first, why would we
decide to go global?
OK.
Why we decided to go global.
As many of the
developers here probably,
not the ones that are
like Cartoon Network,
but more the ones that have
started as entrepreneurs,
we found that there was a
problem, especially when
kids from our nephews or
sons were trying to use apps
and they were basically
all in English.
So we had this big
problem that we
were trying all the
time to translate
what the voiceover said.
And I imagine in
Portuguese happen the same
a couple of years ago, there
weren't many alternatives
in this specific field for
the early childhood category.
So we were asked all
the time, and especially
in these past three years,
why would you go global?
Why wouldn't you focus, for
example, in the Spanish market.
That we are from Argentina,
we kind of know the language.
And we can make a
different on that.
Or why wouldn't you focus in the
US market that is more mature,
and you have better chances
of making more revenue.
So we thought at that moment
that this particular issue
was going to be global.
Like many, many people
from all over the world
were going to use the
apps in English only.
And they were going
to have this problem
while trying to help
their kids learn
useful stuff like the alphabet.
On the other hand, we found this
opportunity three years ago,
that when we
started the company,
we found amazing translators
and crowdsourcing services.
That probably 10 years
ago, if we had this vision,
would have been
much more difficult.
But at that specific
moment, we found
it was quite easy to
get talented voiceovers
in several languages.
I'm going to tell you we
are localizing the apps
in 15 languages.
And also, it was very
inexpensive, and also very easy
to implement.
So I think once you start
seeing our metrics in downloads
and how after localizing
it started to grow,
probably more than
one of you will
start thinking in localizing
in languages like Asia
or Eastern Europe
and other countries.
So this graph, I like it a lot.
Because when we
launched our first app,
it was an animal sound.
So very simple.
But we launched it already
in three languages.
It was in Portuguese, in
English, and in Spanish.
As you can see, probably,
Brazil was our first country.
And that was for a
period of 12 months.
We have over 35% of the
traffic coming from Brazil.
Then we have around
40% traffic coming
from Spanish-speaking countries.
Then US, about 9%.
So we launched the app.
And immediately, we had
like 84% of the traffic
using their app in
their native language.
Which was great.
The feedback we got and
the reviews were amazing.
Because people were
actually surprised
that we took care of different
languages in one single app.
And then we have
countries or languages
like Indonesia,
German, and India,
that were in the
long [INAUDIBLE].
But we were still obsessed
with these last statistics.
We were obsessed that
16% of the traffic
were using the app in
a foreign language.
And we said OK,
this is happening
like the same happened to us.
It's happening in
countries like France,
in countries like Italy.
So they are using an app,
and translating the app
to their kids.
So what we did right after,
we took localization--
that was something
that has been said
a lot today-- super serious.
We decided to create
a global team.
I'm going to tell you how.
I'm going to share
our method to do it.
We had to decide at what
point which languages were
going to be included.
Because there are
too many languages.
And we have to make
at least one cut.
And the decision
for us was pretty
easy we left some got
some low language.
These are countries
that potentially
may be very good for
revenue, but short in reach.
And we decided to go for a mega
big in the emerging countries,
in emerging markets.
So we cover languages like
Indonesia, Arabic, Hindi,
Malaysia, Philippines, all with
voiceovers in those countries.
Well, that that is the
hardest part, to get quality
voiceovers.
But everything is localized.
Even the logo is
localized in India.
And we were crazy trying
to understand if we
made the correct understanding.
But it turned out great,
and I'm going to tell you
a little bit about it.
And then we knew
that we were going
to fail on so many levels.
Especially because we were
facing other cultures.
And, well, people have
different visions.
For example, in some
countries, something
that you think that is
good culture for you
might be completely the
opposite in another culture.
So we started to check
the reviews all day.
And started to respond
and understand,
which were our
weaknesses in our apps.
And we had a lot.
But we started to,
after conversation,
we started to
improve that a lot.
So this is our graphic now
two years later of the same
that I have shown
before after localizing.
So basically, you can see
here all the blue countries
are the original languages
that we already covered.
Brazil is still in
position number two,
still like in the top three.
But then we are in a
lot of new countries
that are in the top position.
And see, he's happy.
Like Indonesia, it has like 10x
growth in every year for us.
It is massive.
They are downloading
the apps like crazy.
And there are some
other countries
that are-- we say that we are
experimenting in this emerging
market revolution, but
only the beginning.
India, France, Turkey, Italy.
France and Italy are
obviously not emerging.
But those are the countries
that are now in our top
10 in downloads.
And for us, it's amazing.
Because it drives
different questions.
Like for example-- I
don't want to go ahead
of the presentation--
but you have
to think of different
business models for all
these variety of countries.
It's not like the
in-app purchases
that costs $6 in the US
is the same in Indonesia.
Because they have different
acquisition power,
they have different
payment mentality.
So it drives a lot
of good questions.
So what we did was we did
something that we call,
inside the company,
we did a big audition.
Like American Idol, we
felt like Simon Cowell,
analyzing all kind of voiceovers
from all over the world.
And we interviewed more
than 300 voiceovers.
Because we needed to
cover 15 languages.
I see you are very happy.
Because actually it was
like a complete process that
took about two or three months.
We knew that we had to do create
a great team that would join us
for the rest of the app.
Because it was like you get a
voice over that the kids like.
Then you cannot not
change because that people
doesn't work anymore
as a voiceover.
You have to find quality people.
And then we had the
other challenge,
which was smaller but still.
We had to find quality
translators and editors.
Because especially when you
work in the kids' industry,
you need to be very delicate
about everything you say.
And we found this good team that
now is showing all our games.
So final result,
after 400 people
that we interview in
this big audition,
we have now a staff that works
with us, 25 voiceover talents.
We cover 15 languages.
So we have 10 substitutes
for any kind of thing.
And then we got 30
translators with editors
that help us review
and check descriptions.
We have some very-- we
have all the time things
that we would get from
the editors' team review.
For example, last
time, a week ago,
we had one word in Russian
that says like child, girl.
And there was our little symbol
missing that says poison.
So we get all the time
these kind of situations.
But it's something you
can solve quite easy.
So process took about two
months, like I was saying.
But the good thing
about this is that now
localizing an app for
us into 15 languages,
since we have all the text
in the first language,
it takes only 20 days.
So it is very easy.
And once you start thinking
in the products that
will be global, it's pretty easy
to, in the technological side,
it's much easier if
you start thinking
in being global from scratch
than trying then to, well,
start making some fixes.
So these are
another funny thing.
Because when we
started, we obviously
start revising everything
with our ears, our Spanish.
We understand a little
bit of Portugese.
English, of course.
And then we have a little of
Italian that we understand too.
So we knew that one
of the challenges
was to reach the same
quality in all languages.
For example, we said we need
to reach the same quality
Malay-- I don't know, the
crazy language for us,
we don't understand
anything-- as in Spanish.
That was our KPI.
So we have to do a lot of
understanding and reading
reviews.
And this is a very
good example of how
a simple thing in the content
can change a lot the reviews.
Like in the Arabic language,
we weren't that aware,
but the pig is a very
prohibited animal.
Like in the culture,
and especially for kids,
it's like if you show the
pig, you're messing up.
Like don't do it.
So we got a lot of reviews that
says that the app is quite good
but you cannot show
this to my children.
We were oh-- we don't want
to start doing this game
that we have to adapt every part
of the game to every language.
But the reviews kept
coming, kept coming.
And the rating came
really down until 3.9.
So after removing the pig,
now the Arabic language
is the first in our rating.
And that is something I think
is a good example, of how
by understanding
and reading reviews
you can do a massive
improvement in your ratings.
And this is how it lies
in our animal sounds
app, which is the one
that has more downloads.
That's around 4 million by now.
This is the top
languages in rating.
So obviously, Spanish,
we speak Spanish.
And we don't believe that
in Arabic or in Russian,
we were doing better.
But I think this is a very
good point to understand,
and for you to know
that in those languages
there are many options
available for kids.
So the users really
appreciate when you create
quality content for them.
So it isn't possible, I
think, to get better quality
than your native language.
It seems to be very even.
But there is a plus because you
are doing it in a language that
is not very common.
And well, there is a
very funny-- or example,
there is Indonesia.
Indonesia, I was saying,
is the first country
in downloads with this app.
But we have the lowest rating.
It's 3.98.
And after reading reviews, we
understood what was happening.
They used to say [INDONESIAN].
[INDONESIAN] became like a word
all the time in our head.
And [INDONESIAN] means I'm
going to try the app first,
and then I'm going to review.
It happens that they forget
to update the review.
So this is a very
interesting examples
because sometimes
you think that you
have something
wrong in your app,
and it's something cultural.
And we ask for reviews to
the users on a certain time,
like in the third
or fourth session.
So it might be a
good idea to start
thinking, for example,
in Indonesia, don't
ask right away.
Because the users
have this commitment
to put a review and
then evaluate the app.
So these are the kind
of things that we are
learning by using the reviews.
Well, there is always
some percentage
of the people that say the
in-app purchases are expensive.
But that is a main
issue, [INDONESIAN].
At last, this is what
we are more focused now.
Because we have the
app available in-- we
have downloads from 140
countries in 15 languages.
So we obviously
know that it isn't
fair to have the same price
for example in Germany
as Indonesia.
It just doesn't work.
Like the percentage
of paying user
is ridiculous, if you have
the same pricing in all.
So we knew that the new
feature of the pricing
tiers and the templates came
out, we started testing a lot.
And I have three things
that I would like to share.
Like experiments that
might be some highlights.
So what we did, I will
explain it very simple.
We did a division
of three tiers.
We created a team that was the
top 15 countries in the world
that spend more in gaming.
And we put them in
the first column.
Then the second like countries
like Brazil, Argentina,
that spend more less
than, let's say, Japan.
And we put them
in the second row.
And then we have
the other countries
that spend less, or are
more oriented to ads.
And we put them in
the third column.
So basically, the first
column had 100% of the prize.
The second, 70% of the price.
And the other, 50% of the price.
That was the experiment we
were trying to understand
if that made a difference.
So for example, in
countries like Russia,
when we did this 30% discount,
we saw a 70% increase in sales.
And this is, like, if you start
doing this on every country
and start focusing, you'll see
that there are differences.
But it is very impressive the
growth we have seen in Russia.
Russia is one of our top
15 countries in downloads.
Then we put a reduced
price in Latin America.
And we saw that it didn't
make any difference.
For us, at least, it
is just a percentage
that might pay or not.
But in that specific case,
when we reduced the price,
we had the same amount of
people, but just less revenue.
But it's interesting
to see and try,
because maybe the
price is still not
very attractive to users that
are willing to spend $1 or $2.
And then at last-- this
is just very simple
and we were very
angry we didn't do it
before-- we saw a significant
increase by just rounding up
the Euro price.
Because the Google Play console,
if you do the outer comparison,
it rounds, for example,
from 0.99, it was 0.89.
8 I think now it's
out of comparison.
But when we understood
that, we said OK,
we have to round up every price.
Because probably
it was confusing.
People will say why is it 0.89.
And we saw in
countries like Italy,
we had like 45-50%
of increase in sales.
So that is something
very easy to do.
And if you have apps distributed
there, I suggest you do it.
So I have been
showing some results.
But I wanted to show you more
the big picture of how once we
started localizing,
how it turned out.
So we took here two countries,
Italy and France, as examples.
Let's say that Italy
and France were having
without the localized version.
So when we were having
the three languages,
let's say 100
downloads every day.
So after localizing
just the first month,
we had three times that amount.
After six months,
we had four times.
After a year, we had five times.
So I think it shows quite
good the huge potential
of localizing.
Because if you do it
on a regular basis
and with 15 languages
like we did,
we had like three times
the downloads in general.
And there are some
countries like Indonesia
that the growth was 10 times.
So I really suggest you do it.
And before localizing, Asia
and Europe was only 18%
of the traffic.
And after localizing, it's 51%.
And the other localized
languages are still growing.
Not like the ones
that we localize now.
But this gave a huge
percentage of new users,
especially in revenue.
So this are, I think,
the last two charts.
This is how it looked
like, our revenue,
top grossing countries in
Google Play before localizing.
So basically, we had US, Brazil,
Mexico, Argentina and Chile.
After localizing, we had
the increase or interruption
of countries like Italy,
Germany, and France
that are now in our top
five countries in revenue.
And this is
something, since all,
or the majority
of the developers
are always focusing in English,
it is the most important
language, it's important to
point that now for us, English
is still huge, like
44% of their revenue.
But the other is much bigger.
And all combined, we strongly
believe that emerging markets
will start gaining
every time much more
in revenue and in downloads.
So expect to see this emerging
market revolution happen.
So the last chart
is our top four tips
of why we think
users find valuable
in this specific
thing, in localizing.
So number one is having
native voiceovers
that can give clear
instructions to children.
Especially if you are
producing jobs for kids
under the age of five or
under the age of seven,
it's hugely
important for parents
to have someone that is
guiding the experience.
Then we usually, every day we
enter into a console and answer
reviews in their
native language.
And that's, sometimes we
get two or three stars.
But after replaying in
their native language,
the outcome is usually that
they at least put four stars.
And we get a lot
of updated reviews.
Like we get the
e-mail and we check.
And it happens a lot.
So we also localize everything,
the [INAUDIBLE], the title.
We even tried localizing
the icons and put a flag.
In the last [INAUDIBLE]
here in Brazil,
we see that that
was working great.
Turned out that once we
did the icon experiment,
that didn't work as we expected.
But still, we tried to
localize everything.
Even the app title,
screenshots, everything.
And at last, this is
something that we learned
by knocking our head a
few times against a wall,
if you start
localizing everything,
it's very important
that you start thinking
in not including a lot of text.
Because you are much more
willing to do errors.
So the more images and the more
voiceovers you can include,
that's the better.
So thank you.